for two decades Gunsmoke ruled the
television airwaves CBS aired 635
episodes of the Western a record for a
scripted primetime program but that
record will soon be broken tomorrow
night
Fox airs the 636 episode of The Simpsons
would you do it
can't let you break my record
[Music]
The Simpsons made their debut as a
series of animated shorts in 1987
there's nothing to worry about
now everyone gold is sleep good night
Homer and company were so popular that
two years later Fox decided to give the
Simpsons their own primetime series the
show became an instant hit and it was
clear from the start the Simpsons was no
ordinary cartoon executive producer al
gene has been with the show since the
beginning writers and animators
everybody has just worked so hard and
preserving the quality of the show I
think that's one reason we're still
around with 29 seasons 32 Emmys a
Peabody a hit feature film and popular
merchandise The Simpsons remains a
cultural phenomenon and groundbreaking
franchise my whole life has been leading
to this one moment that's called pride
[Music]
the face poof
their own I love that too and this tells
you what a huge achievement that is
these are the the top running primetime
TV series right there and as you can see
they've not only passed Gunsmoke they
passed lassie Law & Order and Ozzie and
Harriet that kind of sums up my old
childhood
note to self there are three of those
yeah oh yeah amazing quality TV yeah
that's an extraordinary achievement